target number two has been spotted in dc
another one of captain lewis's
lieutenants her name is sergeant daniels
an army veteran and sadistic killer
daniels is known for her brutality and
unwavering tendency towards public
execution of civilians in the street
[Music]
[Music]
michelle daniels
her great-grandfather was a proud
confederate soldier her grandfather an
army man
her father an army man
and her brother an army man
a proud and male-dominated family with
deep roots entrenched in patriarchy and
service to their country
the loss of her mother during daniel's
birth meant that she never truly had a
maternal figure to help advise and guide
her while growing up
maybe the softness of a mother could
have shaped her differently made her
gentle and possibly even meant a
different path in her life
yet irregardless she grew up tough she
had a hardness about her that even the
boys lacked
she was gritty callous and at times
indifferent and cold
taking her life was easy
there were never any regrets and why
should there be it was her right
she was an apex hunter
others noted with alarm her seemingly
dismissive nature in regards to taking a
life
when she fished when she hunted and that
sharpening her rifle skills was more
important than anything else
yet her father always insisted that
daniel's demeanor was just the result of
not having a mother growing up around a
multitude of males and adopting a tomboy
attitude in order to survive
contradictory to her father's efforts in
stopping the rumors daniels never felt
she needed to justify herself
her attitude had always served her well
in the past and this proved successful
in the army as well and she took immense
pleasure and testing and pushing the
boundaries of new recruits to see if she
could break them
unsurprisingly her actions were noticed
by her superiors and as a result she was
repeatedly written up for objectionable
behavior unbecoming of an officer
after serving in one tour she returned
back to her life and hometown as
civilian
there she began to work for her father
in his tackle shop and hosting guided
fishing tours on the potomac river
unsatisfied and discontented with this
lifestyle a year after leaving the army
she enlisted with the national guard in
the hopes of finding some excitement and
to stave off further boredom while also
continuing to work as a river guide
with the outbreak of the deadly virus
the national guard was activated in
washington dc and she like so many
others would eventually be merged into
the jtf
anything and everything necessary to
save what remained daniels was undaunted
by the task and ready to get to work
but eventually she became aware of
antoine ridgway his ideals and his loyal
men the true sons
this was the moment she'd been training
for
finally a leader who wasn't afraid to do
what was necessary
someone she could admire
who would appreciate her strengths and
recognize her indifferences towards
others and death to be assets
rather than liabilities
not long after agent dusk defected from
the division she met daniels
and they would become strong allies and
friends
after antoine ridgway's death when the
true sons were demoralized broken and
severely short on supplies and weapons
dusk make contact with schaefer to
negotiate the terms of him providing the
true sons with support
nervous about going to meet him alone
dusk reached out to daniels for backup
desk to sergeant daniels come in daniels
this is daniel's what can i do for you
dusk you free tomorrow not really what
do you need i've got to meet with
schaefer he didn't show for the last one
something feels off
could really use someone i trust to have
my back oh i thought you wanted alone
time with your boyfriend gross
gross
i don't know what fey is thinking
working with him i don't know if i can
trust this guy ah he's black task but
he's a boy scout we talking about the
same schaefer he want that back up or
not better safe than sorry
i can't make it but i can lend you a
couple of guards thanks daniels
i owe you one
more like 20.
in order to get the food and the
equipment for a true sons to survive and
rebuild dusk would have to join schaefer
on an operation he would soon be
carrying out in dc
dusk and her guard of true sons were to
run point in the southeastern districts
of the city capturing multiple sites of
interest in east mall south west and
capitol hill
but ultimately this was a suicide
mission
merely a distraction
dusk and her accompanying true sons
would one by one be hunted down by the
division and eliminated
and eventually even schaefer would end
up being captured on coney island
daniels took the loss of her friend very
hard and demanded revenge
so she approached general anderson for
orders on how to proceed
general anderson status report division
took dusk off the board that's too bad
we need to counter-strike
uh negative daniels
but she was one of ours she was a true
son
she was a rogue agent first she was one
of us but she was also one of them and
with loyalties as fluid as dusks
there's no way to know if she was
playing her own angle no no no no i sent
my men with her and in time we will
avenge them but not today
we need to see how this plays out
schaefer's to blame general
we don't know that for sure but i will
look into it personally we can't keep
working with the black tusk
they're a liability you may be right
there are too many rogues in their
organization
who knows what they're really planning
and with alice in their pocket
proceed with caution
general anderson simply brushed this off
as an acceptable loss
to whom dusk was a turn coat and would
have more than likely done the same
thing to the true sons when it suited
her yet he did agree that working with
the black tusk was potentially the wrong
direction going forward
after the death of feylau at camp white
oak sergeant daniels was sent by captain
lewis to washington dc as part of his
specialised team
there she seemed to be looking for
something as reports indicated a
multitude of civilian interrogations
acted out by her personally
but it would seem she wasn't getting the
outcome she needed
general anderson yes sergeant daniels
how can i help you captain lewis said i
should talk to you
i want permission to use
advanced interrogation techniques
sergeant i know that if i can push them
a little harder
i can get them to tell us what they know
about the i don't need my permission to
do what you feel is necessary i trust
your judgment thank you sir if your
methods produce results that's all that
matters oh i'll get the answers we're
looking for thank you for being so
thorough a true son leaves no stone
unturned
we'll root out these snakes
anderson was happy to oblige especially
if it would get the results that the
true sons needed
however these are the actions that would
put daniels on the division's radar
agents would catch up to sergeant
daniels in downtown west where she and
her true sons had set up a stronghold
capturing strategic points throughout
the district
one by one they were taken down and at
the bank headquarters division agents
and daniels met face to face
although she was well defended and her
troop of true sons fought hard the
agents were able to persevere and fight
through
and eventually take her down
i feel like i need to address the
elephant in the room
accompanying these last two targets in
the season 9 manhunt there have been
some very spicy fellow comms that have
come through
i keep getting asked what i think of
them or why i haven't talked about them
yet and that's fair these certainly
changed some things that i've talked
about in the past some quite
significantly
but i've been sitting on them for now
letting this new information sink in
while my overactive brain starts
connecting the dots throughout the
entire division 1 and 2 story making
sure i haven't missed anything
i promise before the next manhunt target
is released i'll be digging right into
these new comms so keep an eye out
otherwise thank you very much for
watching this video and i'll catch in
the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]